bonsoir a tous fait la une de
l'actualité le mariage pour tous les
députés vont attaquer une nouvelle
séance de nuit à l'assemblée
c'est un débat qui qui passionne la
france ne m'en parle dans les déjeuners
de famille le dimanche matin dans les
dîners en ville si je puis dire
il ya des manifestations dans la rue il
ya des gens qui sont venus prier devant
l'assemblée nationale à genoux devant
l'assemblée nationale
c'est là des débats qui vont avoir lieu
le jour la nuit les week-ends donc il
faut être là en permanence
[Musique]
nous serons simplement plus nombreux
pour chanter le temps des cerises et
guay rossignol et merles moqueurs qui
seront tous en fête est nul n'aura peur
des chagrins d'amour à la fin de la
première victoire il est 5h40 du matin
samedi matin vous imaginez il était donc
en en séance depuis la veille et cctc
incroyable quoi débat marathon une
nouvelle fois les débats se sont tournés
vers la gestation pour autrui plus que
sur le mariage pour tous vous êtes en
train de créer un précédent
vous êtes en train d'assassiner des
enfants la majorité de demain remettra
l'ouvragé sur le métier que vous le
vouliez ou non
on avait la force de frappe de la ddt 22
24 25 journalistes de la chaîne qui se
consacrait uniquement à ça retient
aucune eau qu'aucun média aucune chaîne
qui pouvait faire ça non mais regardez
le spectacle vous attend pas de données
je vais lever la séance je vous préviens
des fois c'était des classes mais il y
avait il se passer véritablement des
choses quoi
ne prenez pas la lourde et grave
responsabilité de violer des millions de
conscience aucune différence ne peut
servir de prétexte à des discriminations
d'état fait des belles audiences a très
bien marché on a été des cours pris sur
eux pour les autres chaînes donc oui on
avait vraiment le sentiment que là il
fallait qu'on soit à la hauteur
malheureusement c'est pas tous les jours
qu'on avait comme ça une loi qui faisait
autant débat dans la société et que donc
il fallait bien le traiter l'assemblée
nationale a adopté le projet de loi
ouvrant le mariage aux couples de
personnes de même sexe et donc voilà on
a eu le sentiment on a senti si je puis
dire un peu love le vent de l'histoire
commencé dès voilà c'était de toute
façon qu'on soit pour ou qu'on soit
content c'est un moment important dans
l'évolution de la société française
[Musique]